so let's get into the the propagandists
oh this one's a little too personal for
me I've been harping on this for a
minute but I want to make this very
concise for you guys so you can
understand what's going on in Australia
we I have these series of tweets that
break down what's happening in Australia
very simply I said don't forget if the
chief minister says you can't leave your
home even to get food
thanks the Army for their trucks used to
transport covet suspects and you get
arrested if you try to leave the camp
Jesse's single and Colette say it's a
conspiracy theory
so here we go here's one article under
that lockdown residents could only leave
home for five reasons including
essential shopping essential work
providing or receiving care exercise and
obtaining medical treatment Gunner has
announced binjari and rockhold residents
now cannot leave their homes unless for
medical reasons or in an emergency that
means you can't leave for food we have
this from gravian Chief Minister Gunner
the Army is now transferring positive
covet cases and contacts in Northern
Territory Australia to quarantine camps
by army trucks and finally NT police
arrest three people who escaped from
Howard Springs covid quarantine facility
the propaganda and the men and those
supporting the the state narrative in
this regard is probably the scariest
thing to me because what ended up
happening today was Jesse single wrote
this entirely fabricated story about me
claiming that I was like a conspiracy
theorist or something based on my tweets
literally quoting
abc.net dot a u which is to say 38
people were transported by Army a truck
to the quarantine facilities I Never
Said by with guns drawn or by force or
anything like that he then writes this
big article that's completely fake
seemingly just to kind of discredit me
now of course I know that's personal and
I I take a a emotional issue with it but
I decided to put together these three
sources which I included the links to
all of these stories on Twitter and
surprise surprise many people didn't
know this was real so a lot of people
engaging in the Twitter spat I had with
Jesse see these three stories and their
response immediately was no way that's
real because if you read these
propaganda stories from like Colette or
Jesse you'd think I made it up when in
fact it's all News Guard certified
sources in Australia they have police
and military setting up checkpoints and
locking down people in their homes the
chief minister has said you cannot leave
your home for these reasons for for the
normal lockdown reasons meaning no food
he then said I'd like to thank the Prime
Minister for the ADF personnel and army
trucks to transport the covet cases and
the suspected cases and close contacts
to the Howard Springs facility all of
that was said from his mouth
I feel like Colette is kind of going the
way of um the mainstream media which is
a little bit troubling and I think it's
a really good reminder that we need to
be incredibly critical of all of our
sources even if we think that they're
mostly or some percentage in agreement
with us ideologically it's also pretty
terrifying what's what's happening in
Australia where the government
previously disarmed the citizenry very
interestingly no one's really bringing
up how gun confiscation worked really
well in Australia anymore I remember
hearing about that a few months ago I I
don't hear about that right now ain't
nobody in Australia would take up arms
against what's going on probably but but
still I think it's a factor worth
considering here but when it came to
these three escapees I remember seeing a
news report showing how police officers
were closing down roads and inspecting
every single vehicle searching
everyone's cars to make sure that no one
was hiding trying to make these people
uh get away from the larger area so they
they caught these people but but this is
this is again absolutely huge powers
that the government is granting itself
in the name of a tragedy that that of
course has historically gone down with
people exploiting uh really bad events
for their own personal powers and the
powers that they have in Australia I
mean the authorities there have rushed
through laws that give them the ability
to control people's social media
accounts to hack their accounts to see
everything that they're doing to deny
them the ability to be able to walk into
businesses heavy fines for not wearing a
mask heavy fines for going to protests
jail time for people organizing protests
and when you when you're seeing human
rights eviscerated to such extent where
you can't even voice an opinion against
the government without having the
government knocking on your door saying
we want to control your social media we
now have the ability to post as you when
we want we have the ability to know
every little detail about your life that
is a dangerous
power that you have given the government
that of course it routinely historically
always abuses I want to give a special
shout out to Colette and to Jesse single
too because if there's one thing they
accomplished in making up fake stories
about me or lying is that they've just
gotten me to cover the issue in Greater
detail more and more I love it so I mean
it look it was initially I tweeted
concentration camp in reference to
Howard Springs as kind of like a jokey
trolley thing and Claire decided to go
nuts on it so I doubled down and now
we're at the point where I've covered
this in great detail and it's only
getting worse now there's man hunts for
people who are escaping from this uh
quarantine facility and uh and Jesse
decides to write a completely fabricated
narrative about me based on a tweet
without doing any research that's that's
the funniest thing about it and in turn
I obviously get mad about it and then we
cover the story in Greater detail once
again simplifying that in Australia they
are rounding people up with the
assistance of the military and the chief
minister is thanking them for the
assistance sending them to a camp where
they're trying to escape is Claire in
Australia right now clearly is so is she
in a position now where she got online I
was like you're right Tim what the
government's doing here is horrible we
need to do with that they'd come
knocking on her door yep probably yeah
of course I mean there's incredible
videos showing police officers showing
up at people's doors banging demanding
saying did you post this on the internet
were you here at this protest did you
dare have a voice against the state
intimidating people harassing people not
just protesters journalists like uh what
What's his name yemi uh I forgot it
yeah yeah uh
avi's been doing really incredible work
he had police show up at his door he's
routinely detained for even trying to
report on these protests as an official
member of the press so when you have you
know intimidation of of Journalism when
you have have the suppression of
people's voices when you have the
suppression of protests when you have
the suppressions of people's speech you
have a situation that is absolutely
orwellian destructive dangerous and the
opposite of anything Progressive that
anyone could even imagine want to know
what the best part is about these three
people who escaped they were teenagers
and they had tested negative
the Australian government took three
teenagers from the banjar community
brought them to a quarantine facility
when they were negative for covet tested
them they were negative and then when
these three teams escaped the police
were sent out to investigate hunt them
down and arrest them set up roadblocks
are they there though if they're
negative yeah they were near someone I I
have to wonder about the Australian
government bringing not people without
kovid to a quarantine camp where they're
not allowed to leave and then you have
to imagine these teenagers are probably
thinking I don't want to get covid yeah
and they're like you're negative they're
like good let me go no wait were they
positive maybe first and then they were
negative
so what the it's possible but the
minister said close contacts so that
means like right okay well you know we
got uh you know my brother's downstairs
you are officially a close contact
they'd come to your house and arrest you
and be like well you know you were close
contact with this person you might be
like I didn't see that person I know
what you're talking about too bad the
best part about it is how they say
they're not doing it by force and now
you have all of these I swear look
people need to understand
it's a known fact that governments use
sock puppetry on social media the bot
accounts I'm not saying every person's a
bot but they do they do this and it's
funny to see the propagandist coming out
and tweeting it's been confirmed this
people are not being taken by force and
I'm like are you kidding then why are
they escaping like they're they're
voluntarily showing up and then trying
to break out that makes literally no
sense more importantly they voluntarily
voluntarily show up but can't
voluntarily leave how about we'll just
call it that okay the Australian
government is offering free rides and
army trucks to the quarantine facility
where people aren't allowed to leave by
threat of arrest is that it is that are
we good now do you think it's possible
they just don't tell them that they
can't leave once they get there and are
they maybe misleading that's definitely
possible I think it is completely
unreasonable to make the argument that
when the minister comes out and says you
can't leave your house to eat and we're
going to take people with by army truck
to quarantine facilities where they will
be arrested if they escape the idea that
they're voluntarily going to this place
is absurd you know I don't like is the
way the Australian police interact with
the citizenry like gorillas attacking
like a wounded lamb like they just walk
up on people no fear like their arms are
out like they're about to Grapple so
like they're not afraid of getting shot
in the chest because they've disarmed
the populace and they just like stumble
towards humans and like use their Mass
to like squeeze them it's disgusting one
question I have about the Australian
camps is our vaccinated people able to
get into these camps do they detain
those people too yeah probably for sure
positive yeah or if they're a suspect
one of the big things too and we'll get
into this in a little in just a second
is that
um there's new travel restrictions where
uh Biden wants to implement them that no
matter your vaccination status if you
travel into the country you've got to
quarantine for a week you've got to have
a negative test before traveling and all
of these like
I don't know what's uh what's the word
for for the the zealots all of these
like hardcore government mandate zealots
are like what do you mean I've got to
take a test in quarantine I'm double
vexed and one guy tweeted like I'm
double vexed and boosted I refuse to be
treated like these dewormer people it's
like what did you think was gonna happen
dude bro
get your subscription now promo code
fauciology to your monthly vaccine
booster
like I think if people want if people
are concerned about their health you go
and talk to a doctor about it I think
covet is very very serious I got it and
boy was it bad but I think the problem
is they keep trying to centralize
everything they keep trying to say we
have an idea this one thing will solve
the problem when in reality it's gonna
be a multi-faceted approach that solves
this it's not polio this Jim Cramer guy
acted like it's polio like like we're
dealing with polio any any and then he
was like so he said polio is horrible
polio was horrible so we need to use
vaccines against covet like complete
non-sequitur irrelevance also other
vaccines for polio and smallpox they
took years to get men wasn't it 15 plus
years some were like five or six years
others like 15 years but never broke
before has it been right away as it has
been with covid oh so they didn't rush
out of vaccine for no no no no no and
there's also the danger of of rushing
something that will have an effect that
of course will stop the natural
progression of a virus and potentially
even make it worse that's what some
scientists are speculating right now
that this intervention could actually
cause to a worse situation another
different variant that could hurt the
world even more which if you're thinking
about how the state has been using this
problem to help their friends to conduct
the largest transfer of wealth and
recorded human history to empower
themselves with god-like authority over
the population I would think that they
would have an interest in making this
situation worse personally myself but
that is just my own perspective my own
personal opinion some scientists are
speculating this as well but again the
data the science it's still all coming
in it still really hasn't been figured
out but to jump to conclusions to say we
need authoritarianism we need tyranny to
solve this problem is absolutely
ridiculous it's a stupid idea and it's
an idea that Joe Rogan argued recently
is hurting more people than actually
helping more people and I think that
argument has a lot of Merit to it I'm
still surprised how many people say that
the vaccines are a way to end the
pandemic that they stop the spread of
covid like so many people still say that
it's like no no it's mainstream science
that that's not the case that it slows
the spread temporarily that's the most
accurate way to say it thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time